all right joining me now with reaction
former US Attorney Joe to Geneva House
Oversight Committee ranking member Jim
Jordan and former deputy independent
counsel Robert ray doesn't get better
than this tonight Joe what does the
impressive scope of this new probe
initiated by Barr tell us tonight James
Comey Brennan and clapper have said to
themselves which one of us is going to
pay the bar bill the bar bill is coming
due and Durham's appointment means that
the already occurred meetings between
the Attorney General the CIA director
and the Director of National
Intelligence have now focused on a laser
that the core of this conspiracy began
with John Brennan and ends with John
Brennan in London and DC and the
Democratic National Committee this is
very serious business and for the first
time I now believe that some of these
guys are going to go to prison Wow you
mentioned Brennan tonight and we
Chrisman Jordan we got some profound
sound from both Brennan and clapper this
was Brennan today explaining what's
going on with this new probe let's watch
it went through a rigorous due process
within the Department of Justice the FBI
it was approved by the FISA Court it
went through all of those steps what
they're trying to do is to uncover
something that they will misrepresent as
being part of this deep state effort to
try to undermine Donald Trump's election
it was all copacetic congressman it was
suitably went through the FISA Court
they you're investigating the
investigators it's an embarrassment you
heard it no he uses her misrepresent the
only misrepresentation is what they did
with that with the dossier in front of
the FISA Court where they didn't tell
the court who paid for the document they
didn't tell the court that the guy who
wrote it
Christopher Steele was tonight I mean
other networks are pulling a this is
Fantasyland for concern this is very
serious I think it's bill barr doing
what he said remember when he was in
front of the Senate Finance Committee
four weeks ago he said he was serious
about putting the other team to get the
bottom of this he said there was a four
key things there was a failure of
leadership at the upper echelon
the FBI we know that's true he said
spying took place he said it twice he
said there's a basis for his concern
about the spying that occurred right and
finally the two terms used I said this
last week in the committee hearing he
used two terms that should scare every
single American he said unauthorized
surveillance and political surveillance
those things are not supposed to does
China does they're there in Robert Rey I
got to get you in on this because
they're accusing they accused Trump but
basically spooning with Vladimir Putin
to get to get elected okay and Yin yet
they use autocratic disconnect to toriel
means to surveil the Trump campaign to
get the information that they claimed
was going to be of course it not never
was there and now we have the DNI
involved and we have the CIA involved
with the man is serious as bill Barr he
was not cowed one bit by what they tried
to do to him last week was he Robert
well congressman Jordan is right I mean
this isn't a question about whether the
procedural steps were followed this is a
question that first is exploring bias
and whether that had an impact on what
was or wasn't disclosed to the FISA
Court which to answer your question
Laura is a serious issue there's a case
in the Supreme Court about this Frank's
versus Delaware which all prosecutors
and agents are familiar with and it's a
serious question now that's going to be
explored by a prosecutor after all this
is not duplicative of Michael Horowitz
his investigation because the IG doesn't
have prosecutorial authority to actually
bring charges but in this instance now
as the result of Bill bars appointment
there is going to be an investigation
the purpose of which is to determine
whether or not any crimes were committed
which is Jodha Jennifer's point crimes
committed this is this is now explaining
why they threw so much mud at a man like
Bill Bar with the history and the
reputation he has what's the most
dangerous thing out there someone who
has nothing to lose bill Barr made a lot
of money in everything you need Ennead
this job right you never kick the bear
oh no and let me tell you something
Horowitz has already concluded that the
final three phases were completely
illegal he's now on the brink of finding
that the first FISA was completely
illegal Durham has already used a grand
jury in Connecticut they've already
gotten documents he's already talked to
the Intel people how long has this been
going on do we really know how it during
working for a couple of months so the
bottom line is this this is now big time
this is where Brennan needs five lawyers
Comey needs a lawyer
are they lawyer DUP sufficiently I hope
Comey has someone other than mr.
Richmond to whom he leaked his memos his
little Patrick Fitzgerald the old
another prosecutor I don't like nothing
like a sleazy Posner represent there's
another horrible he did the Conroy
materials terrible horrible prosecutors
also that's the US attorney who was also
looking into Jim Baker the former chief
counsel yeah yeah so that's where that
that investigation was also taking place
I think that's I think that's
interesting that's who bill Barr
selected and it's not just the dossier
remember what we learned two weeks ago
the New York Times reported that the FBI
put someone posing as someone else in by
George papadopolis keeps talking about
this yeah those are two cases where well
I want to play I want to play
Papadopoulos we also have to play Bernie
Sanders who is out there tonight talking
about this but I want to play
Papadopoulos first since you raised it
congressman I want to get you and Ray
and Joe to talk about it let's watch I
fly to Greece I have dogs sniffing for
money I leave the money in Greece and
then arrested in a savage like manner at
Dulles with agents rummaging through my
bags looking for money so clearly this
was some sort of sting operation and by
the time it happened the special counsel
was appointed he was caught up in this
there dangling money at him at least I
mean and this was they all knew how this
was all gonna go this was all rolled out
according to plan until it wasn't they
put somebody posing as somebody else
with George papadopolis and start asking
all these questions early on in this and
this entire investigation that was what
kicked it all off up supposedly correct
I can July of 2016 so bill Barr has said
he's going to get to the bottom of it
he's now appointed
someone to head that team up that he
said he was gonna point together that is
a good thing let's get to the bottom of
this so that nothing like this if
everything that we think happened did
this should not happen in the United
States of America and that's what we got
to prevent we still haven't gotten to
the bottom of the Hillary Clinton email
scandal which is the other thing they
have to touch but I've got to play this
Bernie Sanders of course one of the
Democratic frontrunner had this to say
today about the launch of this new
investigation Trump does all of the time
he tries to divert attention from the
realities and the problems that are
associated with the White House or in
fact his campaign
you know I understand it what the FBI
did is they had reason to believe that
there was collusion and they
investigated at that collusion so no I
don't think we should be investigating
the investigators of course not Beth
shoe on the other foot he'd be a doing a
candlelight vigil right now Robert
former as a former independent counsel
do you agree with Bernie here no I mean
the president is right at the conclusion
of the investigation the Moller
investigation is over to wonder how we
got on this path to start with I mean
isn't that an appropriate question to
ask I mean I'm not going to prejudge the
outcome I think you know unlike
Democrats you know there's there's no
point in singing about what may come or
what prosecutions may unfold but clearly
it warranted a second look that was why
there was an IG investigation and now
the handoff is complete it's now in the
hands of a prosecutor with prosecutorial
authority who will make a decision about
whether or not any crimes were committed
and whether or not it's appropriate to
be bring charges against those who were
responsible I mean that's what you
expect the Department of Justice to do
don't you I mean that's about the
Department of Justice to do not sign off
on phony days I mean build our said it
was a big deal it is a big deal I mean
it's a big deal
liberals used to care about civil
liberties no matter whose civil
liberties were being tread upon trod
upon try to prescribe trod upon thank
you Joe basic air works s doing it with
my kids essays every night checking
their grammar I go check my own but I
gotta guess what some is this Don junior
deal they cut some D
for him to testify for the Senate Intel
committee or it should burr in a saddle
what is going on I would have told him
to stick why is John Don you junior
galactic use of the fifth the look I was
not right now in the house in the Senate
with Richard Burr who is a disgusting
Republican chairman I'm so sick of
Richard burr burr this phony Republican
from North Carolina listen Don jr. has
every right to believe that what's
happening is abusive and vindictive
just like everything that's going on in
the house no citizen has to take that
they can invoke the Fifth Amendment
because they're innocent and don't want
to be put through a perjury I didn't
have any problem Lois Lerner and Vulcan
the bark waters running that committee a
Democrat that Samaras that calling him
back based on the testimony of a guy who
went to prison ladies were lying to
Congress when he came in front of like
seven times death that's why they're
calling bad that makes no sense guys I
could do a whole hour with this panel
love this panel thank you so much all
three of you